[Applause]
you guys congratulations on this show I
mean movie star TV star and now a
reality star covering all the bases
always we're gonna have each other's
back it's quite ironic that he's the
last person that wanted to do this
reality show yeah he sees the camera and
he's like
am I in French that's the truth
everyone's gonna love you guys your
brother fresh air I mean of course we
have seen so many famous families take
on reality what do you think is going to
set your show apart I think ours is more
of a dark document I think it's funnier
and I think it's funny
and I think that we all have such big
personalities there's nobody quiet no
personality and we're very loud and
funny we're quiet as people on earth
okay we come from love like everything
we hate each other
did you draw any inspiration from other
shows I mean of course we've had the
Kardashians on TV forever yeah I
wouldn't say inspiration would you I
mean no I would say because they're
unique in their own way they've done it
so right and it worked for them and
there'd just be no point in trying to
accommodate us too like maybe inspired
you to do something or do something
different that's now you hit it yeah now
you hit it you want to say how do we
differentiate ourselves from them and
that's like being your authentic self
yeah and that's what we are my sister
and I run a podcast called unwax
it doesn't get much better than this
brain wise body wise looks wise we're at
our Peak ladies why was now the perfect
time to do this show with your family
well certainly I'm not getting any
younger but Tulsa King has brought me to
like another level and I thought you
know this would be great to share this
kind of like new notoriety with a
reality show while you're still relevant
see what I mean and it's the ultimate
movie I love I mean ultimate home movie
I love my daughter I love my wife and I
want to like share that yeah because
it's something that I think is
entertaining
and more time with your family that's
really nice and obviously our matriarch
here I imagine you know you're you're
the you're the protector here of this
family and you know there's some things
that maybe you don't want seen is there
anything off limits with the show I
think the bedroom the bathroom
brushing our teeth that type of stuff
okay but basically we are very real it's
more of a docu-series we're not we don't
really hide we're not shy people I'm
very honest I always honestly say we're
almost too honest of who we are and so
that's what I really wanted to share
with people I didn't want it to be set
up I didn't want it to be like oh we all
get drunk and we all throw fits and
we're screaming at each other no because
that's not what we do and I just wanted
to show people real life things that
happen with dating she's Scarlets in
college it's you know trying to figure
each other out being the oldest I've
always had this pressure of being very
perfect dating with the last name that I
have is incredibly hard being a Stallone
holds a lot of weight now you girls I
mean what has been the biggest perk and
also the biggest disadvantage of having
Mr Sylvester Stallone as your father and
having that last name growing up I think
for Me Maybe for all of us it's when he
would leave for a long time growing up
and then he'd come back you know it's
it's tough not having your dad at a
consistent rate all the time and we
understand it's this industry but that
was probably the hard part growing up
was like those big moments of how bad to
miss I would say the best thing is here
like a never-ending Encyclopedia of wise
wisdom yeah yeah I mean I feel like
you've lived 10 different lives so
anything I mean when it comes to
relationship advice to work advice to
Friendship advice he just gets it
because he goes I've been there and I've
lived it yeah no dating is that a
disadvantage you're already rolling your
eyes there I imagine you know bringing a
boyfriend home that's gotta be very
intimidating because either they're
trying to like square up to him and be
him or they're in love with him well he
also doesn't help he stands in the
corner sort of says nothing looks
through his eyebrows that's for the
first like three or four dates he won't
say anything and then does it change it
I mean women have a certain unspoken
language instead of men and it's like
but you're gonna you're deaf definitely
gonna be a mush when you walk your girls
down the aisle one day aren't you
you're gonna take me in a stretcher
with a tuxed over there
he'll have like 10 bucks
and then he's gonna try to drag him back
now can you guys live with us can you
would that be great no your husbands are
gonna be like oh my god there was a time
where I was I was scared of him and now
here he is exactly have you ever have
you ever tried to set them up with
anybody that you know or a co-star or is
that like you will not nope
we've given him ideas but then he would
absolutely turn him down in two seconds
it's nobody's good enough oh sorry sorry
guys what that's a dad thing you know
how it is I I fall in love with all
their boyfriends she loves it and I I
honestly get I start crying if they
break up and it makes she's more upset
than we are I get more upset and then I
tell them not to break up with him and
he's celebrating and he's celebrating he
says no he's writing there I write the
Macy's day parade he actually writes
their breakup text
you've written I'm sorry you've written
their breakup text yes guilty
what did it say I'm a good writer I mean
you don't want to hear it he's written
40 screenplays I think he can write it
that is true that is sometimes though he
does want to end it with keep punching
I'm like that doesn't mean that might
give it away yes I delete that part but
everything else is so good have any of
the guys caught on to this no no no
it actually is the best
he did he gets the best
[Laughter]
well I'm a mom so I like I want I want
everyone to be in our family and I feel
so sad because I'm gonna miss them oh my
goodness no my mom's advice is forgive
them it's okay they made a mistake my
dad says dump them
give them 10 more chances so they're
good boys I love it you said you want
everyone to be part of the family I'm
I'm coming over just let me know when
Christmas Day
so much fun how long do you want to have
cameras in your space do you see this as
a long-term thing as long as the lettuce
that's an interesting question I think
I don't know when the patina wears off
but definitely for a couple Seasons yeah
we'd like is anything that you guys are
nervous to read
probably I break up um
polished Scarlet's in college so I think
she's a little nervous going back to
college after all her College friends
maybe see it yeah yeah it definitely
sets the tone I mean they did already
talk about it now the buzz is going
around college and they did interview
Kids on Campus not that I wanted
there's a moment with a couple of
tarantulas they may not want to go
through
I don't want to say it
there's a tarantula you guys will
I can't believe you guys are actually
doing a reality show I would have
thought you on TV like this you're
welcome
[Music]